thank you very much for joining us it's
just after attend GMT and we start this
NewsHour with the war in Ukraine the
commander of Ukraine's Ground Forces
says his troops are advancing on the
Russian occupied city of bakmut footage
just released by Ukraine's Army appears
to show Russian positions Under Fire
near the eastern city moscow's forces
declared Victory there last month and
Russia says meanwhile that it stopped a
major Ukrainian offensive elsewhere in
the Eastern Donetsk region those reports
have not been independently verified but
Moscow has released pictures it says
show some of the fighting
pro-ukrainian forces meanwhile have
launched a raid in the Russian border
region of Belgard one of the groups
involved the Russian volunteer Corps
says it captured several Russian
soldiers cave is denying involvement
in a moment we'll be speaking to
journalist Julia chapovalova in Moscow
but first we go to a chance Stratford in
Keith Charlie a very complicated picture
of the front lines tell us about what
you're hearing is happening in bakmut
and elsewhere in the Donetsk region
foreign
to get any kind of independent
verification about these claims being
made by both the Russians and the
ukrainians the ukrainians are saying
that they've made a few gains we
understand to the south of bahmoud but
what we also know is that the vast
majority of that town is very much under
the control of Russian forces I think
more interestingly of these claims that
are being made by Russian forces that
ukrainians made or made an attempt and
advance in what they say was five
sectors of Southern Donetsk again no
reaction from the Ukrainian side in
relation to that claim but if anything
the ukrainians have launched a campaign
of Silence in recent days and weeks they
released a video the Ukrainian military
released a video showing Ukrainian
soldiers bringing their fingers to their
lips saying that the public and the
military men of whom actually post their
movements sometimes on social platforms
like Tick Tock to keep quiet
we understand though that the timing of
these claims is is uh is Salient because
of course it was only a couple of days
ago that the leader of this country
President Vladimir zielinski said the
counter-offensive was about to start or
that they were ready to start it the
Russians from their part have released a
video showing a a green field and what
seems to be military vehicles being hit
in that field we can't independently
verify whether in fact those Vehicles
were ukrainians or indeed Russians but I
also think that it's important to
recognize that if indeed this this claim
by the Russians is true and that this
move was made by the ukrainians trying
to push South through southern Donetsk
then that is consistent with what we've
been hearing with military analysts over
the last weeks and months building up to
this counter-offensive and that is that
they expect Ukrainian forces to push
South through zap
in order to try and reach the as of sea
and what that would do would basically
cut off this so-called land bridge
between Russian occupied areas of
Donetsk and nagansk in the north with
Russian occupied Crimea but as I say
it's almost impossible to get any kind
of independent verification of these
claims and counter claims by both sides
so no official confirmation of whether
this is the start of this long-awaited
Ukrainian counter-offensive what
challenges do the ukrainians face uh
Charlie when it comes to this
counter-offensive
well there are huge challenges ahead and
and that's not lost on the leadership of
this country as well in fact you know
president zielinski has said as much but
military analysts will tell you that
some of the most important things that
they're concerned about
um is just how thinly for example so
much of this Western military equipment
or military equipment from allies could
be spread along a front line that is
around about a thousand kilometers long
they also talk about the length of time
that this counter-offensible
preparations for this cancer offensive
has given Russian forces to thoroughly
dig in and defend their positions they
also talk about the kind of straight
changing strategy that is going to be
needed in order to launch a major
counter-offensive they talk about
something called sequential movement now
up until now the Russians have sorry the
ukrainians have been using Heavy
Artillery for example and what limited
air power they have to strike Russian
targets before then moving into infantry
forward analysts say that there needs to
be far more of a simultaneous
complex military move in any major
counter-offensive and whether in fact
the ukrainians are ready for that
remains to be seen and just to give you
an indication of the kind of risks
um that the ukrainians are facing in
fighting on that front line then
analysts will tell you that the kill
ratio is always very much in favor of
the Defenders The Defenders obviously
being the Russians in this instance and
that kill ratio is around three to one
so there are huge challenges that the
ukrainians will face when this
counter-offensive eventually starts
Charlie thank you very much for that
chance Radford live Forester in Kiev
let's get the view now from Moscow and
speak to journalist Julia Chapel Valia
what are the Russians saying about
what's happening on the front lines in
Ukraine
so the situation seems to be very
complicated indeed now I'm talking about
the Donetsk direction as well as the
city of bahmoud we've been getting
reports here about some heavy attacks
and the large Advance by the Ukrainian
Army in several directions in the
Donetsk region and the Russian forces
have repelled a major Ukrainian
offensive in the southern Ukrainian
region around Donetsk and ugleta the
situation escalated first of all near
uglida where where a report about heavy
fighting there right now the ukrainians
managed to enter the outskirts in the
village of Novo donetskoye several other
villagers were also attacked in the
Donetsk Direction but according to to
the Russian side uh well the ukrainians
actually couldn't achieve a success in
that direction and having lost people
and several pieces of equipment the
Ukrainian rolled back
and they've been attacks Julia inside
Russia tell us about what's been
happening in the belgarad region and who
are these fighters who are infiltrating
Russia from Ukraine
well earlier there were reports about
the uh the liberty of Russia a legion as
well as the volunteer Corps the Russian
volunteer Corps that penetrated into the
territory of the Russian Federation of
the Belgard region that borders uh
Ukraine so basically those Legions those
groupings they are claiming that they
want to free Russia and at the moment of
course uh the the main focus is on the
border region of belga road right now
because it is the hardest hit region
right now so in the morning the
Ukrainian Army fired more than 70 shells
from the grand multiple launch rocket
systems and they attacked the village of
nowhere in the border with the shabekina
and the Belgrade region that according
to the head of the chabekino district
and locals say the town of can has
literally been wiped off the face of the
Earth and right now there is no
electricity water or mobile phone
service in the city and a number of
shops have been looted and many people
say that they don't have any savings to
run away from there and settle in other
parts of the country and therefore they
rely on the help from the government
from the state and some people have been
taken to Temporary accommodation centers
and basically they complain about the
conditions at those centers as well
Julia thank you very much for that Julia
shop of one of our live there in Moscow